[Music]
all right edger I thanks so much for
being on the second episode of exit
strategy podcast super excited to have a
conversation with you I feel like you
and I are both in the e-commerce space
and we've never met although I've met
Jack before so excited to meet you yeah
that's a pleasure thank you so much for
having me on it's a little bit about
your background you were a the
co-founder and partner at atomic and the
CEO of hims and hers right now is that
right okay looking forward to this
conversation because I think that every
every company that I talk to you today
wants to be the new atomic and can you
tell me first how you describe atomic is
it like is it an accelerator is it like
an incubator how do you describe time
yes atomic is something pretty special
it's it's neither a venture fund nor is
it a studio model essentially atomic is
a company if you sole purposes to build
other companies so we have a group of
twenty or thirty individuals there that
are all operators and entrepreneurs and
we diligence at that between 20 and 30
businesses per year and end up spinning
out and evaluating the ones that we see
the highest potential in and then going
and funding and founding those companies
with other co-founders that we bring
into the fall so it's really a it's a
team of operators that have a phenomenal
access of pool of capital and great LPS
like Peter teal and Marc Andreessen and
we use that capital to build the
companies that we have seed and have the
best promise and the most signal from
all of our tests internally okay so Tom
like tries to test out 20 to 30
different business ideas per year one of
those business ideas was hims and hers
is that correct that's right and how
much money does like atomic spend in
order to test a business idea
so you've like atomic has raised money
independently of hims in hers and hims
and hers is really raised money
independent that's right how much the
money does a Tom expenditure to test a
business idea so traditionally we'll
start with something like 50 to
five thousand to get a little bit of
signal and then it might expand up into
a hundred or two hundred thousand but
you're talking about relatively small
seed checks necessary for one or two
individuals to build prototypes get data
call people try to sell things
try to understand product market fit
positioning price points offers etc and
then if then when we get that data we're
able to actually look at it relative to
to ten or fifteen other companies that
are in that incubation process and look
at metrics side by side to see where
outliers exist so for example with hymns
and hers you know the the crazy part
about that company was we used about
fifty thousand dollars to get that
company started and with fifty thousand
we built a prototype over the weekend
and this was in you know 2016 a
prototype over the weekend that would
let men download a mobile app and answer
questions about their health and then
sign up for a package relating to
different types of medical conditions
that they were worried about and that
prototype it was it was called clubroom
at the time and that's because in my gym
there was an old deodorant bottle called
clubroom and I said okay that seems like
a good test name what's wrong with that
so we literally got this thing up and
running two or three people on a weekend
and in the first five weeks of that
prototype we did a million in sales
signing up for for the offer and again
nothing was built yet it was signing up
for a waitlist they put in a credit card
and then I would manually email them and
say hey you've been added to the list
you know total total really testing
right kind of zero to one face but that
that cost just fifty thousand dollars
and it was at that point that we were
able to look back look into customers
that had come in look at their profiles
look at their willingness to pay and
decided that there was a real demand to
go and build that company and so how
much you spend fifty thousand dollars to
build a mobile app how much would like
cold clubroom how much of that is done
internally versus externally look or
your operators sort of developing the
apps and putting them on the App Store
or do you get to that externally so all
of that is internally so we
you spend money on Facebook ads to try
and get people to download the app and
sign up that's right depending on on the
company whether it's a consumer app you
might try traditional distribution
methods like an Instagram or Facebook or
Google or Direct Mail or radio or
whatever it is if it's a b2b company it
might be sales to tests like sales calls
automated calls and understand price
points and offerings but essentially
that capital is used to build the
prototype and find what I like to call
some type of proprietary distribution
channel that gives us confidence we can
scale this business successfully not
only that we know how to build something
that's amazing but we know how to get it
in front of people in an efficient
manner that gives us confidence we can
we can grow this company in a unique way
and so aside from hims and hers what are
some of the other idea is that you guys
have launched yeah there's quite a few
so a company bungalow which is a cool
living company based in the proscenium
as well over there or they've raised
quite a lot of capital from Khosla
founders fund a lot of big names home
bound which is a construction company
it's helping families during natural
disasters around the country rebuild and
have that supply-demand model actually
be much more efficient so that people
can fill the homes much quicker much
easier much more on time much more
capital efficient and that companies
raised maybe 40 to 50 million from
Google Ventures and thrive capital
there's a company terminal which is
actually a remote education company that
brings together recruiting and
engineering into one hub so you can
imagine this company going around the
world building amazing hubs for
engineers to come learn and work with
Silicon Valley startups hims for example
we've been a client of this company for
many years most of our engineering team
is scattered through Mexico and through
Canada and they all live in different
terminal offices so those are a few er a
few of the the most recent companies
that have broken out and raised you know
maybe 40 or 50 million in the last time
can you give us an idea of like three
companies that you thought would break
out and didn't like you know what I
really love about Bessemer
Ventures is that they have this thing on
their website would they have the anti
pork like you know we missed the
opportunity investment Airbnb at FedEx
seven times at Apple I feel like all VC
funds to do that like whenever I was
trying to raise money I was like that's
where should be the first company I go
to do because they're like humble about
their origins what if what are a few of
the companies that you guys try taking
bait and didn't work out particularly
guys who got past phase one past the
$50,000 and got into now $150,000
yeah you know there there's a lot of
them right and then that best summer
page is I think one of my favorite pages
on the internet frankly I think it's
incredible you know there was a sleep
apnea company we have family members
that have suffer from sleep apnea
there's about thirty to forty million
people in the United States at have
sleep apnea and the process of getting
diagnosed tested and actually getting
the equipment for CPAP machines is is
excruciatingly painful and expensive and
so the idea was could we make that
easier for people to do diagnosis and
treatment and actually get the equipment
could make that business work then that
was a really unfortunate one that we
tried there was a business in pet
insurance his years ago I was really
passionate about this everyone loves
their dogs willingness to pay for your
animal is in many situations higher than
a willingness to pay for yourself or
your partner couldn't get the economics
of the business to work so this was a
pet life insurance or pet health
insurance a pet pet life actually was
pet his pet health insurance I'm sorry
not life insurance okay so yeah you know
there's been there's been a lot of them
and most of the ideas that hymns and
hers are really internal ideas right
it's it's things that that us as
partners are really passionate about and
really want to exist in the world and so
hymns and hers was one that I was very
passionate about wanting to exist
terminal which allows you know any
company to hire dozens of incredibly
talented engineers from anywhere in the
world very quickly that was something
that us as founders as always we've
always wanted and so we like building
businesses that we you know can really
resonate with and I think that's where
you know we've had a lot of success is
just there's
that instinct and building something
you're passionate about and then we're
like as these ideas sort of are born and
grow up how do you how do you staff then
so you know for hims in hers it's easy
you're the co-founder and a partner at
Atomics it's simple with bungalow with
terminal do you hire internally defined
CEOs or do you look externally yes we
you what we do is something called a
founder and residence program so at any
given time at atomic there might be five
or ten individuals that are internal
founders that are working with the
partners and working with the operating
teams so prototype and test ideas and
they are really the leader is taking a
charge of bringing those tests to market
and so when bungalow for example Andrew
and Justin are the two co-founders of
that company they were founders in
residence with us for many many months
looking into a vast range of ideas and
we're prototype many ideas as a group we
saw incredible signal around the co
living space the desire to live in a
city the desire to have a more
affordable life the desire to live with
people in a community and they were
really excited about it and we were
excited about it and so we jointly
decided to found that business together
and so in almost all circumstances the
founders of those companies started as
founder residents operators internally
helping us evaluate ideas and then they
choose a path once they get that passion
and that conviction for an idea and so
that happens and that happened with you
with hims and hers and then and then
what is the next step so you've got a
conviction around it well I guess first
you do clubroom this is this app is
clubrooms just available for when you're
pitching clubroom and running ads for it
are you running ads for like certain
types of things are you saying hey we're
gonna provide you with you know the
generic version of propecia we're gonna
provide you with generic version of
Viagra or is it one or the other or is
it yeah when we were pitching clubroom
it was it was a range of all those so
when we were we were exploring what
conditions for men really resonated most
at in an efficient at an efficient CAC
worthy of holding a business right and
so at the end of the day these
companies really are successful when you
can build a recurring engine right
there's a willingness to pay there's a
margin structure and there's a
proprietary set of distribution channels
that allows you to pour an amount of
capital into that and grow the company
and so you we we look looked at a range
of different medical conditions that
have different margin profiles different
medication offerings and then went to
market and tested those to get a good
sense of what men would be willing to
pay for each of them so you test price
point right out of the gate as well
price annoying offering the whole thing
and so after you've spent the $50,000 or
$100,000 sort of proving the business
model you raise you got to raise money
right you're gonna need a team you're
gonna need to build a much better app
that like where you're not manually
emailing customers do you raise money
from atomic or do you go to VC's yes so
at that point into its mix of both so
atomic has a large fund that's able to
contribute in two rounds
what I did and I think what most of our
founders have done is they they bring in
other or create partners into the round
so that you get even smarter people that
are experts in its different areas
depending on your business and so for my
company went when I decided to found
this we decided to partner with Kirsten
green at forerunner and Josh Kushner or
at thrive the two of them are you know
incredible human beings some of the best
investors I've ever worked with today
and still to this day are exceptionally
valuable and involved in the business
you even on a you know week tweet basis
but they were truly experts in how you
revolutionize old industry with new
behavior new business models new brands
right it's really moving that from you
know Harry's and Warby to Dollar Shave
Club and the chat glossier and bonobos
and the list goes on and on and so at
that point when we decided to build hims
we raised from those two funds anatomic
also participated in that round and that
was really our seed financing and how
much did you raise in that seed
financing you know don't quote me on
this but it's summer I want to say
between five and six million I can
really reserve and what's the what's
been the total fund raise to date and
can you talk about valuation I'd
certainly seen that you're a unicorn
certainly got to be nine figures that
you've raised how much have you raised
what's that valuation well yeah
we've raised over 200 million today and
and yes the last the last public
valuation was was over a billion dollars
and and so that's kind of where we're at
right today gotcha
and then can you talk a little bit about
structure I'm curious because you know
when uh when you're building a business
generally
you know the founder controls the entire
business until they start raising money
and then VC start owning a share of the
business
and at some point either the founder
still has majority share or doesn't have
much already share but there was really
like to parties founders and D seats
here there's a third party where there's
atomic so who sits on the board who
controls the board like what is that
structure look like yeah so the way we
think about anatomic is it is
essentially that your co-founding your
company with the time atomic is a group
of operators that are highly incentivize
to make sure that all of the companies
we found are wildly successful it so
there are a number of partners at atomic
each of those partners will take lead
with different companies and with
different founders and and and be
essentially the operational lead for
atomic with that company and so the way
you think about it is as you join atomic
you're going to be co-founding your
business with a huge group of
individuals and this group of
individuals from strategic finance
distribution marketing sales strategy
accounting legal HR are all available to
you and and not on a kind of as needed
service basis but truly as a part of
your team and so it's a pretty
incredible advantage that allows me as a
founder or anybody else as a founder to
focus on the one or two things that
actually matters for your business right
and that might be building the brand it
might be finding the distribution
channel it might be sourcing the product
but but it allows you to co-found the
business at scale and so structurally
that's what the business looks like your
co-founding it and you're splitting
equity depending on the situation and
then when you raise external capital we
are all equally diluted by that external
capital and so who decides for his
external capital look do me the
you know I was a member of the
I was a you know residence member an
entrepreneur in residence at an atomic
and I was like okay great this business
is working you all sort of agreed to
that I go out and pitch funds am I
making the call is atomic making the
call or like what's happening there no
the the the CEO that gets put in place
and is taking charge of that effort has
complete autonomy to make the decision
of who they want to work with what
partner is what be sees you know at this
point atomic and Isis partners have
worked with you know the vast majority
of GPE is at the funds in the valley and
so we can give guided based on expertise
or specialty or past experience with a
certain fund or a certain set of
individuals but it is always that
individual who finds that kind of
personal connection with the board
members and the new investors that they
want to be bringing in gotcha okay so it
sounds like the CEO has a lot more
autonomy and can you talk about who sits
on the board of hims at hers or is that
confidential the the board is
confidential at this point but it's
fairly reflective of the major investors
in the company so just like any other
structured startup and board your
primary investors are the ones that are
taking board seats for the company
gotcha okay okay I want to dig into hims
and hers a little bit more and I think
we're maybe where I can start is where I
can I can start by explaining what it
does and you can correct me if I'm wrong
since you're actually running the
business perfect you know it's a men's
wellness brand and well hims is a men's
wellness brand versus a women's wellness
and basically you're trying to make
medicine available that has been
scientifically proven to do what it does
without the headaches and inconveniences
I mean to walk into a doctor's office
get pretty you know get a prescription
and do a bunch of before you
get your medicine
I think that's a good way to put it you
know the way I'd put it is that hems and
hers is a healthcare company that makes
it easier for you to get access to
experts and the medicine and treatments
you need for a range of dozens of
different conditions you're worried
about that's a great weight so if you're
you know like when I was doing research
about hims and hers I saw I you know I
read a bunch of other interviews that
you've done you said you did a million
dollars in sales the first week that you
launched the brand that you launched
guys and that was the worst week you've
ever had that's right
that's absolutely bananas like you know
in 2013 like Casper which at the time
was certainly the DTC darling of the
world did a million dollars their first
month and everyone was like how is that
humanly possible and you've like move
the bar much much higher to do a million
dollars in your first week I'm out there
somewhere that's gonna do a million in
their first day in the next few years
yeah yeah I'm sure there is as well and
like you know I hope it comes out of the
top and I'm sure the bar is move move
can you talk a little bit about how you
achieve the million was the million
dollars in sales the first week
generally results of you going to guys
who'd signed up at club room saying hey
come by this or was it something else
and more importantly week to you did
another million dollars how did you get
those customers in the door yeah it's a
great question so you know the way in
which we did that and I think reflecting
on it was having a very solid
understanding of the type of guy we're
gonna go after the type of messaging
that worked type of brand that resonated
and the type of offering that we knew
they wanted to buy and so you know while
people say we did a million dollars in
our first week they think okay what we'd
launched and all of a sudden when we
started learning that first day when we
started learning people just came and
started running towards us and I think
that's where there's a big big education
gap in fact there was probably two and a
half years before that when we were
really understand
our person right we were getting
customer insights we were talking to men
we're asking them about how it made them
feel to be losing their hair or to be
struggling sexually or to be feeling
like they didn't have energy or they had
acne in their mid mid 20s or late 30s
and that didn't seem right but really
understanding who our person was and so
there was those years of doing that
research and in particular years of
figuring out what is the brand that
activates that customer right and the
some of the key insights were stigma is
a huge problem right there was this
concept of men being too tough to take
care of themselves and brushing it off
and so there's this whole kind of toxic
masculinity that we had to crush as a
brand to encourage and empower people to
go and take care of themselves and so
that was a set of insights there's a
whole telemedicine component as you said
like I'm the last person want to go to
like the doctors and I'll really only go
and less of like bleeding from the head
or I've broke an arm or something and so
if I can make that easier from my phone
90% of our orders take place on their
mobile device talk to a talk to a
physician click buttons answer questions
take photos and then and then I get
access to the things I need it like
that's make it simple right so there is
these insights we knew needed to happen
and so you know well we had an
incredible first week and I think it's
an amazing sign of the success I don't
want to you know undervalue the fact
that it was probably two years of work
to understand the customer in order to
launch on that day and say we have a
high degree of confidence what we're
launching people are gonna love because
we've been talking to them for a really
long time definitely I absolutely think
that's really worthy of being said you
know one of the other things I saw when
I was doing research for this was that
multiple branding agencies have taken
credit for building buildings that's
right
can you set the record straight who was
the branding agency that you guys
actually worked with so we worked with a
lot of granting agencies to be totally
honest and what we did was and this was
I think some of the secret sauce because
some of the insights coming out of this
were you could build dozens of different
types of brands but we knew we wanted to
do was build a brand that
good cross-gender we new hymns and hers
or men and women together was gonna be
critical because we had this idea of a
future healthcare brand and that wasn't
only men and it wasn't only women and so
we didn't want to build a brand that
only segmented two men we wanted to
build a brand that was accepting of
where you felt you were as a man you
could be a young old straight gay black
white doesn't matter but it needed to be
as modern and fresh and leaning into
that that flexibility that modern
masculinity has sure and so what we did
was we actually put about a lot of the
agencies and they came back with
concepts and then from there we filter
down to a couple agent season in
particular we worked with partners in
Spade now in New York which i think is
one of the best branding agencies in the
world and what we did with them was
actually designed multiple brands so we
identified them as a great creative eye
talent and strategic talent and we
actually designed five or six brands and
saw how they felt and we sat on them for
weeks literally weeks different names
some of the names or a triple point
McCoy we almost named a company McCoy
there's Admiral was one of them and and
so this process of finding out who we
were really happened with partners in
Spade and then what we did is we took a
lot of that work and we brought in some
expert teams like Gin Lane out of New
York our VP of design is a guy named
Daniel Kanger who ran creative team at
gin lane for a decade he joined us
recently a few months ago and he's been
working with us from the beginning and
we took that brand understanding from
partners and state and we said how do we
know visualize this how do we art direct
it how we put it on sites on mobile
devices and went from there
and so you know the reality is is that
we had a lot of people giving us input
and we had a lot of people designing
different concepts and then what we did
internally at the end of the day is we
are directed every single photo shoot by
we I mean me and Hillary are you know a
co-founder mind and a head of product
right now
we were on the shoot we were writing the
copy we were owning that spirit of the
brand so that really was as pure to what
we wanted to be as possible gotcha
okay so you've got branding coming from
multiple agencies with sort of your
curation and your vision being executed
you've got all this feedback that you've
received from customers and two and a
half years of studying who you think is
gonna buy the product and what you think
the barriers are to buying these
products already you launch and you have
a million dollars in sales the first
week you know one of the things I've
heard you talk a lot about and you
mention this earlier during our
conversation as well as a proprietary
marketing proprietary marketing strategy
which is you don't want to be subject to
the whims of option based marketing
platforms like Facebook or Instagram so
first I want to understand are you able
to advertise on Facebook and Instagram
or are you not able to yeah I'm always
curious what you know you are able to
yeah just gotcha
and then yeah you know those you know I
built an e-commerce business that was
largely based off of auction based
advertising and found it to be
successful but certainly you know a
roller coaster ride what we've told me
some of the marketing mecalac marketing
things that you do that like you know
certainly everyone is seeing your you
know your television ads and everyone
has seen your out-of-home ads everyone
knows that you advertise on top of
journals and you know in the train
station as you work we're are some more
unique things that you guys do and tell
me how this sort of tell me how you're
buying this type of advertising like you
know advertising in trains in New York
anyone can do advertising in urinals and
stadiums a lot of people haven't done
like are you rolling up these stadiums
or is there a third party that you were
working with right so the the way we
think about this is we want to create
inventory not buy inventory and so our
entire marketing team and our entire
marketing strategy goes into every room
they walk into in every store and every
gym and every locker room and every
restaurant and their eyes are looking
every bar and their eyes are looking
around for literally things we could
write that we could have a relationship
with and and the criteria is where is
your turn
cause to her man or woman and it's
different for different medical
conditions right
maybe Edie is something you want to talk
about when you're in a urinal but hair
loss is something you want to talk about
when you're in the gym locker room and
you're looking in the mirror and you're
realizing that you know you're thinning
it top but something like birth control
maybe is appropriate in a completely
different setting for women and and acne
for women is appropriate in a completely
other environment and so this is our
marketing type of thinks about it and
the reason we think about this is
because for better or worse the auction
based marketing channels are effective
and they're efficient and for that
reason companies become dependent on
them and in building companies in the
last decade at atomic I've seen a lot of
companies that become too dependent on
for sure in a negative of course what
happened is the saturation rates as you
want to continue to grow and pump more
dollars into those channels the costs go
up the curves get worse the retention of
the customer gets worse and all of a
sudden you're really stuck in this limbo
and so the strategy for us is we want to
have as little of our capital being
deployed in free market auction-based
platforms and we want to be owning
proprietary relationships with other
partners and so there is no third-party
agency right there's no like Blackshear
market for buying a urinal you have to
go to the SF Giants and say hey I love
the walls and the urinals and and I
don't think you're making any money off
of it what if we paid you X so I'm going
to like the guys who own equinox like
related properties I've been like hey we
want to advertise in the locker room at
Equinox I mean I would imagine they'd
say no but is that something that you
guys have done in the past
I've talked to the executive team at
Equinox many times you know they're
there are a lot of different
opportunities when you start opening
your mind and so yeah you know for
example for all types of stuff we were
sitting in a bar one night talking about
it and I was like tearing I've got this
nerve root hat nervous habit of tearing
the bar coasters right and like pieces
and I look and it's like a Budweiser bar
coaster like well somebody arty was
finally just bah I don't we do that you
know we're sitting there so now if
you're in a New York Bar San Francisco
bar in a good chunk of the bars the
coasters are him
right with hilarious statements and
branded and the amount of text messages
I get from friends and family saying hey
this is incredible I would have never
imagined that it just came from the
creativity that we've empowered our team
to have them hey go find opportunity I
do have to work with both individually
to do that or do it can you do that at
scale with a certain like coaster
manufacturer yeah you try to do both
yeah and you end up having to do both
yeah at a certain point you get
efficiencies and you find individuals
that own multiple bars or network bars
or maybe it's alcohol distributor or
something right but it but it is it is
coming from this first place just kind
of like open creativity of finding
opportunities yeah you know what's crazy
is during this conversation I've
realized that you're the first startup
that is not subject to the immediate
needs of driving revenue today like in
order to build marketing channels like
urinals at SF Giants are you having
multiple conversations with the
executive team that related properties
you need to be able to be you have to be
comfortable with the idea that the
revenue you generate from conversations
you have today will not come from the
press and at most startups they don't
have that type of like timeless you know
you have to be like hey I'm now I'm
gonna have a conversation about
generating revenue in the next few days
and how is that possible is it because
your investors are more long-term
focused is it because you already have
such a large moat in terms of revenue
and in terms of capital or look we're
like why is it that you're singularly
not focused on revenue in the next 30
days he's a great question you know when
I started the company and I think in
part because I've built a number of
companies before the opportunity before
for his and hers in my mind and is to
build a multi-generational public
company like this is a large opportunity
you're talking about probably 80% of
healthcare for moving to digital
telemedicine in the next five years or
so that's a huge huge opportunity maybe
one of the biggest left in that I'm
aware of right you've got to read about
Commerce you've got real estate
transportation and then you've got
healthcare and it hasn't been touched
yet and so you know from the beginning
that was the vision and when I went and
pitched this to Kirsten and Josh I made
it very clear that's what I'm going for
I have no desire for this company to be
acquired you know a couple hundred
million and that's a great exit and then
boom I'm sitting on a beach no desire
like this is one of those ones you
really just put your head down and go
for it and in order to do that you have
to invest in the brand and investing the
brand what that actually means is losing
money
okay you have to lose a certain amount
of money for the purpose of building
equity based value and relationships and
communications with your customers it is
always cheaper to buy an advertisement
on Facebook right or to buy short Google
dad at low volume but you can only build
so much from a true depth of
relationship with customers and the
variation of customers by doing those
types of channels and so what I made
very clear to the investors was we're
gonna allocate a certain amount of
capital to these types of initiatives
where every single month we're going to
be testing we're gonna be learning we're
gonna be making brand investments and
then for the other chunk of capital
which is still the majority chunk of
capital it's gonna be exceptionally
efficient and we're gonna hold ourself
accountable to real numbers and making
money back and they signed up for that
and to this day we still have those
parameters in place where there's a
necessity to change have the percentages
change or are they pretty stones have
been roughly the same and the members
have goes to like the majority goes to
naan bread or like more like I don't
wanna call it direct response but more
like I'm looking for revenue in this
short term versus building brick that's
right the larger bottom first I've been
pressed by your marketing budget then
because like I see like you know I know
how much you know ads in the New York
City Subway cost and those are brand
advertisements right and like that is a
lot of money already and so really
impressed by the marketing budget how do
you work on attribution when it comes to
like the idea that you have these chunks
that are happening today and chunks that
are brand value like we're you know your
tests you know I think that's really
hard like I'll give you an example at
native we were constantly trying to
drive people into stores at Target
Walmart right and so we tried digital
ads and we're like you know do we see a
lift in this certain zip code if we bump
hard these people with ads and and so we
ran those types of those types of tests
how do you know if like you know if
you're owning coasters and you're owning
the San Francisco Giants urinals what's
working what's not yeah so the only way
you do this is through a set of control
tests right so depending on the brand
campaign maybe you're talking about a TV
you identify the zip codes that those TV
commercials went live you look at spiked
attribution and Al assist of the minute
it went live and and the historical
trends before that minute and the six
minutes after that and then look at the
zip code you know two blocks away and
see if you got that same that same day
right so you need big sense maybe the
business of giants is much harder are
you looking at different games and some
Giants is the same thing right so again
90% purchases are taking place on mobile
look at the day games look at the times
of those games look at the traffic
during those games and understand right
and so you can do spike based analysis
based on zip in that type of world and
then the also thing you can do is is
more traditional and this is never
accurate to a perfect degree but at
least it's directionally helpful is post
purchase and pre-purchase surveys right
like how did you hear about us I heard
about you from seeing it on an
advertisement somewhere which
advertisement boom and then you can get
an idea at least proportionally where
that that uncharacterized traffic is
coming from right because it's traffic
that's coming directly to your homepage
everyone will say hey that's free
traffic that's organic
yeah the vast majority of its not
organic you pay for it somewhere and you
have to figure out what bought it from
yeah and can you tell me a little bit
about the marketing channels that you
spend money on today so a big bucket is
still sort of direct response to the big
buckets brand what are the top three you
know there really are no top three
channels it's it's buckets and then
within the buckets are dozens of little
buckets so you've got the traditional
digital channels that you can think of
right
i traditional digital's one bucket right
that's like all the Facebook's and
Google's and instagrams and tic TOCs and
snapchats and dating apps and yeah
Philly all that kind of stuff there's an
audio bucket right you've got all types
of audio people here podcast ads at your
streaming ads that your radio talk hosts
things of that sort podcasts there's TV
buckets right and then there's very
non-traditional buckets that like
urinals or planes flying over Coachella
or coasters sitting at bars or things
like that
is that the order of buckets that we
spend money digital that audio then to
eat now okay
what does look in audio is podcasts the
number one bucket there are the word
podcast as there's like five let me
change the question then in digital is
Facebook / Instagram the number one
bucket its largest within digital okay
what's another one that's larger within
digital well within digital you also
have dating apps you have affiliate
networks you've got partnerships with
education sites right yeah I mean
there's I mean there are again the the
traditional things like Facebook and I'm
not gonna tell you all the things we do
because your listeners need to literally
think about what their product does what
their customers need and then think okay
where are they and how do I talk to them
and so we do that for our customers all
the time that doesn't mean that Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter and all those
are not tested but they're they're not
really the majority they're not the
majority for you the traditional digital
spend it's not the majority I've spent
for you okay gotcha yeah I couldn't
agree more with the idea that like you
know you have to speak to your customers
where they are and what works for one
business won't work for I wish they wish
somebody had told me this list of server
bullets but unfortunately you just have
to really understand who your person is
and then go think about where they're
spending their time couldn't agree more
with that okay so you did 1 million
dollars in sales the first week can you
talk about like revenue or growth year
over year where are you at and from
perspective of understanding that you're
spending a good portion of your
marketing dollars on non direct response
ads but on more brand equity ads are you
profitable or are you not today we are
not profitable we are relatively close
so I'd say you know in the in the coming
years when we want to pull will that
switch we are definitely capable of
pulling a switch which is a great
position to be in
currently we reinvest essentially all of
those profits back into the engine and
grow into new conditions and so we
recently launched a behavioral health
I'm sorry a primary care category that
has everything from like hey you know
asthma and allergies and sinus
infections and UTI Eisley cetera and so
continue to expand on that front from a
kind of public numbers I think what's
public is we've done we did over a
hundred million in sales last year we
did about over a million telemedicine
visits in the last year year and a half
on the platform so that's actually a
patient talking with the physician and
getting a treatment evaluation so those
are like a asynchronous or synchronous
communication it totally depends on the
condition and the state so it's both and
it also depends on what the patient
prefers and then the company's only been
live for two years right and so you can
think of growth rates if we did 100 you
know hundred million in sales last year
it was a pretty fast growth rate from
the year before yeah certainly was
incredible growth I don't think anyone
is questioning growth
[Music]
pretty phenomenal what can you talk a
little bit about categories that are
leading that growth and also whether
it's his or hers that are leading that
growth yeah so the historical categories
which are hymns which have been around
you know a year or two a year and a half
longer than hers are still the majority
of the business right given the time the
majority of things that we are launching
today and that we plan to be launching
this year there's may be I think 50
launches in 2020 that the rolling out
each launches a different medical
condition that a patient can get
evaluated for on the platform the vast
majority of those are hymns and hers
together
so they're they're non gender-specific
treatments and these are things like you
know the majority of things we care
about right people worry about sleep
they're worried about anxiety they worry
about their health or immunity
cholesterol right like big normal human
stuff and so there are they're non
gender-specific and so there's a pretty
big investment from our side to being to
bring those offerings essentially out to
market together with hymns and hers in a
unified way got it and so it is the
majority of the business it can talk a
little bit about categories does it go
like I've looked at some of your
categories I think it's Edie hair loss
and then I think it's also cold sores is
that right those are a few of them some
of the big ones you you've got acne and
anti-aging you then have supplements for
sleep immunity heart health and then
you've got the sexual health stuff which
is you know STDs and erectile
dysfunction as well and for the
anti-aging stuff is it like retinol ugh
is it retinol as you guys are
prescribing or is it over-the-counter
stuff it's also all those categories are
prescription categories so we are
actually compounding prescription
tretinoin in high concentrations that
are custom formulas for your skin type
your age the type of acting your
experience and we're the type of
anti-aging that you're struggling with
and getting those shipped to you
overnight and so do you guys own a
pharmacy at this.look I imagine there's
a lot of regulatory tailwinds that are
aimed that are going in your direction
patents are expiring with Viagra states
are opening up their medicine
telemedicine laws
um do you guys own a pharmacy or are you
working with a third-party both but so
we work with a number of pharmacy
partners in a provider network and then
we also have publicly announced a very
large of a four hundred thousand
square-foot pharmacy operation of
fulfillment center in Ohio that will be
going live in the next few months and
how did you like I guess were there any
you know obstacles when you guys were
growing the regulatory side of things
you know um well let me give you an
example
uber and airbnb those guys were like
look we're gonna do this we're gonna run
into a bunch of regulatory hurdles and
when we run into those regulatory
hurdles we're gonna jump we're gonna
figure out ways around them or over them
and sometimes that's right and sometimes
that's not certainly a little bit harder
with medicine and I don't mean to like
say that yeah I think I think what you
guys are doing is phenomenal and
genuinely providing a real service to
consumers who are either too embarrassed
or can't afford to go to the doctor yeah
so I'm really like I'm genuinely
thankful that you guys exist in the
world um you know we're there regulatory
hurdles or would you like with you that
were air B&B side of the spectrum or
were you on the Procter & Gamble side of
the spectrum um probably neither right
we're somewhere in the middle we've a
you know a very veteran executive team
in these areas in particular you know
our chief legal officer ran the
telemedicine practice at Jones Day for a
decade our head of regulatory or SVP of
regulatory affairs and legislation of
Public Policy ran these initiatives at
lyft and it's square and its benefits
right then that's been doing it for for
over a decade and so our coms executives
ran it at lift as well and so when you
look at maybe lift verse over at PG or
PNG they were they're kind of in the
middle and I think that's maybe where we
fall from a risk tolerance standpoint
you know we are always pushing on behalf
of our customers but we are going to the
regulator's and we're going to the
medical boards in in sit-down
conversations explaining why we think
this is right as a
to breaking the law and then having the
conversation afterwards so I think we
have been very careful
you know to to be as as safe as possible
to make sure that we are the gold
standard for telemedicine because this
market of telemedicine is growing and
changing and adapting so quickly and so
we've kind of put it on ourselves and I
feel like you have that's been a really
important part of our strategy to be the
the talking point to these medical
boards and explaining the benefits of
all the things you said and so in order
to do that you have to keep the
credibility of following the rules and
following the laws and it actually
helped change the laws and we've done
that in a number of states we've
actually had laws changed in the last
few months and in my last couple of
years and I would suspect that continued
to happen as these legislators
understand the benefits of telemedicine
like you know to that effect you know
you're talking about being a gold
standard of telemedicine how do you
think about your competitors you know
some of your competitors are well-funded
some of them less funded is it you know
if people are all prescribing generic
viagra or generic propecia it's sort of
a race to the bottom to that effect are
you his door is your thought process
because hey I want to create you know
proprietary medicines sort of like the
anti-aging which are customized to
people to build remote or how do you
think about separating yourself from
your competitors yeah you know I think
it's really interesting that him to hers
the vast majority of what people buy our
treatment solutions that are fairly
comprehensive and so they might include
like you said a generic pharmaceutical
like finasteride or like a sildenafil or
like about Rex type medication but what
they also include are shampoos and
conditioners and moisturizers and custom
topical solutions and vitamins and not
offering and we see that across the
board when customers come to us they
don't come to us because they are
looking for cheap drugs you know those
options have always existed you've had
online pharmacies Canadian pharmacies
exist for years what we see from our
customers is they're in their teens and
20s and 30s and they're learning
these conditions for the first time and
they're coming because they want to get
educated by a physician and they want a
comprehensive treatment that's custom
and tailored to them and so you know III
think the commoditization of the
pharmaceuticals should happen right
because they are generics and can be
affordable and they should be cheap and
the more that companies exist in the
space the better for all customers and I
think we will continue to be able to
differentiate by offering real solutions
and a lot of times those solutions are
flexibility and options and customized
care and as part of that might include
one of these medicines does that push
back against like this scientific
background of the you know of the proven
medicines so like if you're using
propecia which you know the FDA has said
helps you keep your hair and you're also
selling you know if you're so like rogue
a and I understand that you know they're
also oft a regulated but look are there
like fda-approved shampoos for instance
that product you know keep those allow
you to keep your hair yeah you know
there's always that spectrum right and I
think one of the things that that I
believe is that and this is this comes
from a kind of deep understanding of our
customer our customer when they think
about their health it includes
pharmaceutical medicines on one side and
including food meditation on the other
side and they're both home care like
they truly are about health care right
and so what I believe we need to offer
as a modern platform is flexibility say
hey if you're worried about sleep
there's a lot of things we could do
there's cognitive behavioral therapy if
you haven't tried that it's incredibly
effective
there's things letter over-the-counter
and safe that you can use on occasion
like a melatonin chamomile l-theanine
blend there's Chinese medicine that has
been proven to be effective and then
there's also pharmaceuticals right there
are there there are side effects there
are pros and cons to all of these and I
think what we've seen is that customers
in our demographic that are coming into
their 20s and 30s and 40s they want that
flexibility and depending on the
severity of what they're experiencing
and what they've tried in the past they
might have different spectrums for
different conditions and so we as a
platform one
we are always standing by the statement
that everything on the platform has the
best medical clinical experience it can
have but doesn't necessarily mean it's
always FDA approved sure but when you
talk to a doctor about supplements 9 out
of 10 are going to say if you're gonna
try something that's the one to try yeah
I mean that's really what we're gonna
always lean on that's fair I appreciate
that sort of clarity really quick
questions about understanding your team
size because I know we're running up
against some time I'm how large is the
team of doctors and nurses that you have
on your staff that sort of prescribe
medication we have over 300 physicians
and providers on the platform and how
quickly are they writing prescriptions
is there like a metric where you're like
on average a doctor can write a
prescription like on average doctors are
writing prescriptions every 7 minutes
it's not it's not a metric we we choose
it all the provider networks essentially
have complete independence for how they
treat patients we are the platform
that's connecting the patient to that
external provider network and so they
get paid off essentially on an hourly
basis just to see as many patients as
they're able to see what is the rate of
people that they prescribe medicines to
it totally depends on the medical
condition you know so there are safe
medications when you're talking about
like a Trenton Owen for acne or you
might see you know 90% of those patients
coming through the door qualify for that
medication and maybe 10% based on other
medications they're on do not and then
there's more serious medications like
let's say a birth control that has blood
clot potential depending on the patient
you might have a 50 or 60% prescribed
rate and so it really depends on the
physicians understanding of that patient
and the patient before they get to that
point goes through a full couple like
consultation with that position so
they're talking about the medical
history the drugs they're on any side
effects they've experienced in the past
etc so the range is quite quite large or
just depending on the medicine gotcha
letters like makes a lot of sense two
questions actually two more questions
actually one is how as Kovan 19 sort of
affected the business has it been great
for because no one wants to go to the
doctor and I mean great with the
understanding that this is a catastrophe
for the catastrophe for the world
or has it been taught like how is covin
you know it certainly it affects team
morale by virtue of the fact that all of
you guys aren't able to go to the same
day how is it affecting visitor you know
I think what I've experienced most from
the Cova 19 tragedy is that our team is
energized like I've never seen it before
it is a full-on war time mentality
within within the divisional office at
the moment within slack like I've never
seen anybody on our team act and so you
know we are in a position I think like
many to actually change our priorities
to help the situation you've got a whole
population of people staying at home
those people at home are still
struggling with asthma and bug bites and
UTIs and yeast infections and acne and
and sinus infections etc right but it is
more important than ever for them to
stay at home both for the safety of them
themselves their family and their
community but also to give as much
relief as we possibly can to the health
care system right and not going in and
for non life critical illnesses into
what I've seen is our team be energized
to think about first principles what can
we use our assets for we have physicians
that are experts we have telemedicine
platforms we have a pharmacy fulfillment
brand how do we get things to customers
that can help them and help the health
providers that are on the front lines
and so you saw that we launched the
primary care offering a week ago that
opens up a huge telemedicine platform
and and I hope in the in the coming
weeks and months we'll be able to
continue to expand that to more things
because I think from a business
standpoint that's what I've seen more
than anything is our team is trying to
read prioritize in order to help the
current situation and so it has there
been an acceleration in people's
adoption of telemedicine in the last you
know month I think across the board
there has been an acceleration right
when you have people at home and unable
to go into a physician's office
telemedicine is the perfect solution and
so I think across the board people that
are working in digital environments
whether that's tell education
telemedicine videoconferencing right
like this those businesses are
seeing customers come to them in
exchange for the in-person opportunities
contra okay my final question is about
the state of the director consumer
industry you know I read this quote by
Gary Vaynerchuk where he said 98% of
direct-to-consumer businesses are out of
business right now and just don't know
it basically meaning that they're
addicted to the Facebook's and Pinterest
of the world their unit economics will
never work there's been a come-to-jesus
moment with the failure of brand lists
and with you know the headwinds around
outdoor voices where where's the
industry five years from now look at one
is Gary Vaynerchuk right and where is
the industry five years from now you
know I think there are aspects of what
Gary said that are right there have been
a number of companies and a large swell
of companies in the last couple of years
that have been deploying capital into
open auction based platforms like we
talked about then have completely
upside-down economics and it's not
because they're building their brand and
invest strategically but because
literally the economics don't make sense
right but they're trying to figure them
out and every founder is always working
their butt off to try to make them work
and so you know in an environment of the
last few years when you've had the
capital and the investor is willing to
fund that experimentation it's beautiful
in an environment like today where I
think it's gonna be exceptionally hard
to raise capital
I think flat rounds will be the next two
to three x rounds you know because it
would be so hard to get I think I think
he's right and that a lot of those
companies are gonna struggle to get
profitable and they're gonna struggle to
raise capital and so I do think that is
a reality I think the market has been
able to finance the exploration for a
number of years and we're now getting to
a point where that willingness to
finance the Rd is no longer there and so
companies need to be exceptionally
efficient at finding their profitable
cohorts finding their profitable
customers and channels and focusing on
those because in a situation like we
have right now with the markets and with
cope in 1905 the next year and two you
have grown substantially and I think as
a founder that's the only thing I'm
thinking about and the thing that I
would recommend all other founders
you know and what are the things they've
done to in order to like um in order to
focus on that so if you're if you're
focused on survival or maintaining or
like ensuring that you get through this
crisis
but if you pull back on marketing have
you ever been hiring freezes boring like
look full you know full steam ahead damn
the torpedoes you know so we we're in a
very privileged position in that we have
you know a material balance sheet of
capital in the bank that gives us a
flexibility to get to a point where
we're profitable and so you know we're
not dependent on raising outside capital
which is phenomenal but we did
immediately institute hiring freezes
comp freezes and if we communicated this
to the team saying hey we need to
evaluate the impact of what's happening
to the business we have no idea what
it'll be it might be positive or might
be terrible it might be completely
trivial but until then let's all just
stay calm and let's stay as we are and
learn and look at the data to make
decisions and so we're in that process
right now of evaluating data in real
time as it's coming in day over day and
week over week and until then we're not
making any big strategic moves until we
can get a good sense of what's gonna
happen got it fantastic really
appreciate the time I drove like love
chatting with you love being able to see
a direct consumer business that has a
long-term focus instead of a short-term
one not sure I've ever seen that in the
history of my life before and you know
congratulations a lot of props to you
not only for all the success of atomic
but really hims and hers is the gold
standard of direct-to-consumer
businesses today I hope you're
incredibly proud of what you've
accomplished like you know 20 years from
now you might be looking back on your
life and being like this is gonna be the
first line of my obituary and you know I
I hope you feel that pride today and
don't only feel at 20 years from now
thank you thank you appreciate that
great thanks for the time really
appreciate it awesome
[Music]